the last people I would trust with my
health
is Big Pharma and big government because
neither one of those strike me as caring
entities spoken as the perfect redneck
hippie there was only one thing you know
Ivermectin got made into a you know
horse tranquilizer hydroxychloroquine
got made ridiculous there was only one
thing that could work and that's the
vaccine isn't he laying out a lot more
truth than what you would get from
someone at CNN or the New York Times etc
etc he's asking the right questions and
he's he's making it personal I don't
believe that big government or big
Pharma has my own health in their
interests